All right, this is something a little
different, you know, I get so many emails,
probably like eight to 10 emails a week from
people who either want to start a podcast,
YouTube channel or independent media show or
who have started it. But it's not going as
well as they want. And they want advice from me.
And it's beyond the scope of the 24 hours that I
have in the day to be doing too much of this kind
of individual guidance. But there are a bunch of
different people over the years that have come to
me for advice, people I know personally or people
that are introduced to me. And they often have
very similar questions and the point of failure
for almost everybody is exactly the same. And
I sort of tweeted about this yesterday and a
bunch of people wrote back and said, you should
really kind of talk about this being as not were,
I believe, in the top one percent of YouTube
at this point. And having done it and having
gotten to the point of hiring staff and having a
successful business model, what is it that causes
people to fail? And unfortunately, fortunately or
unfortunately, the good, I have good news and bad
news, and it's all the same. The biggest single
point of failure is essentially not showing up.
When I will talk to people who have started shows
or want to, they often will jump to things like
how do I negotiate a brand deal? What should
my YouTube thumbnails look like? What kind of
equipment do I need for my podcast? When can
I monetize? And so often the cart is being put
before the horse. And what I tell everybody is
all of that stuff will come naturally. You'll
figure that stuff out when the time comes, once
you are actually steadily and consistently and
reliably producing the content. This isn't like
the bogus 98 percent is showing up. This is just
the reality that people will often focus on things
that aren't the most important. Now, obviously,
if your content is terrible, some people just
like, you know, the content is not good, assuming
that your content isn't terrible. Where
almost everybody fails is they get discouraged
too early. There are overnight successes
and independent media. Of course there are,
but the vast majority are not. And people will
come to me and say, you need to pick a content
schedule and stick to it. Are you doing a weekly
show? Are you doing daily YouTube clips? Are you
doing a twice a week show? Or what is the format
and the timeline that you are committing to?
And sometimes people will hear that. And and they
will keep it going, you know, I remember, in fact,
years and years ago meeting up with Kyle Kolinsky
when both of our channels were much smaller.
And the thing we talked about as we both were
looking to grow at the time that he actually did,
and he now has a channel that that is doing
really well, is you've got to commit to the
schedule of content. That's actually
the key thing. We didn't talk about
monetization, brand deals, thumbnails. We talked
maybe about, you know, what microphone do use,
but it was all about the content. And
so I'll have conversations with people.
And 90 percent of the conversation is about
things that don't really make a difference. And
then they'll say, yeah, yeah, I'm going to do the
content. Six months go by, I'll come across their
YouTube channel and it'll say, Oh, the latest
video is six weeks old. You've done no content
for six weeks. And sometimes we'll have another
interaction and they'll say, yeah, you know, it
just wasn't as lucrative as I wanted it to be, is
it? Well, but you're not publishing the content.
You have to do that first. The other big mistake
is sometimes just scaling up expenses before it's
time. I know of shows that are one tenth the size
of our show. We're the host will tell me they
already have an executive assistant who responds
to their email and schedules, their interviews.
What, what? That doesn't make any sense. And I
from a business standpoint, I've talked before
about the push cart method. One of my MBA
professors would talk about the pushcart method.
Don't necessarily go to a restaurant with
an expensive lease and tons of employees
try the food with a pushcart, a food cart. And
if it does, well, then you roll that into maybe
getting the restaurant. And this is like the most
important thing that I that I tell people. And
most of them fail to do it. And there are tons
of shows that could define the contents. Good.
But people just don't show up. And so, you
know, unfortunately, I at this point am unable
to provide individualized advice to all the people
who email me. But if you're not doing the content,
don't be surprised that none of the other stuff
is going as well as you want it to go. Hopefully
that's useful to some people. And I think that
that's what we committed to early with the show,
which was when we were twice a week, we were twice
a week and we were doing the content and we were
putting up the clips in the podcast episodes.
When we went to when when that was supported
financially, we then went to four times a week
and we did it. And then when that was supported
financially, we went to the five and people can
count on the content. It's the most important
thing. It's the biggest point of failure and the
real reason why tons of people I mean, it's dozens
and dozens of people over time who have emailed
me saying I want to do what you're doing, but it's
just not happening. You didn't do the main thing
I said, which is commit to the content schedule.